nous encourageant à signaler un crime sans vous dévoiler.
J'ai l'impression que beaucoup ne sont pas à l'aise
pour se manifester au nom de la vérité.
Je suis professeur de comptabilité et j'étudie la fraude.
Dans ma classe, j'encourage mes étudiants à fournir des renseignements
s'ils en voient.
Autrement dit, j'encourage mes étudiants à devenir des lanceurs d'alerte.
Mais si je suis honnête envers moi-même,
je suis partagée au sujet de ce message que je communique à mes étudiants.
Voici pourquoi :
les lanceurs d'alerte sont menacés.
Les unes de journaux nous le montrent.
Beaucoup choisissent de ne pas être lanceurs d'alerte
car ils craignent les représailles.
Des rétrogradations aux menaces de mort,
en passant par la perte d'un emploi --
la perte perpétuelle d'un emploi.
Choisir d'être lanceur d'alerte est un combat incessant.
Leur loyauté est remise en question.
Leurs motivations, leur fiabilité.
Comment puis-je, en tant que professeur se souciant de ses étudiants,
les encourager à être des lanceurs d'alerte
quand je sais ce que le monde pense d'eux ?
Un jour, je me préparais pour mon cours annuel sur les lanceurs d'alerte
avec mes étudiants.
Je travaillais sur un article pour « Forbes » :
« Wells Fargo et lanceurs d'alerte de la génération Y :
que leur dire ? »
En travaillant sur cet article et en lisant au sujet de l'affaire,
cela m'a indignée.
Ce qui m'a mise en colère, c'était de voir
que les employés qui avaient essayé de lancer l'alerte
avaient été virés.
Cela m'a fait réfléchir
au message que je transmettais à mes étudiants.
J'ai pensé : et si mes étudiants avaient été des employés de Wells Fargo ?
D'un côté, s'ils avaient lancé l'alerte, ils auraient été virés.
Mais d'un autre côté,
s'ils n'avaient pas signalé les fraudes qu'ils connaissaient,
la façon dont la loi actuelle est écrite,
les employés sont tenus responsables
s'ils savent quelque chose et ne le signalent pas.
Une poursuite pénale est possible.
Qu'est censée faire une personne avec de telles statistiques ?
Je suis bien placée pour avoir conscience des contributions précieuses
que font les lanceurs d'alerte.
Ce sont eux qui découvrent la majorité des fraudes.
42% des fraudes sont découvertes par un lanceur d'alerte
comparé à d'autres méthodes,
telles que l'examen des résultats ou un audit externe.
Quand vous pensez aux cas de fraude classiques ou historiques,
il y a toujours un lanceur d'alerte.
Pensez à Watergate : découvert par un lanceur d'alerte.
Pensez à Enron : découvert par un lanceur d'alerte.
Qui peut oublier Bernard Madoff, découvert par un lanceur d'alerte ?
Il faut énormément de courage pour se manifester au nom de la vérité.
Mais quand nous pensons au terme « lanceur d'alerte »,
nous pensons souvent à des mots très imagés :
rat,
serpent,
traitre,
rapporteur, fouine.
Et ce sont des mots gentils, que je peux dire sur scène.
Quand je ne suis pas en cours,
je sillonne le pays et interviewe des criminels à col blanc,
des lanceurs d'alerte, des victimes de fraude.
J'essaye vraiment de comprendre ce qui les fait agir
et de ramener ces expériences dans la salle de classe.
Ce sont mes interviews avec des lanceurs d'alerte qui me marquent.
Elles me marquent
car elles me font remettre en question mon courage.
Si j'avais l'opportunité, est-ce que je me manifesterais ?
Voici donc deux histoires que je veux partager avec vous.
Voici Mary.
Mary Willingham est la lanceuse d'alerte de l'université de Caroline du Nord
à Chapel Hill, cas de fraude académique.
Mary était spécialiste de l'apprentissage à l'université
et elle travaillait avec des étudiants, surtout des athlètes.
Elle a remarqué, en travaillant avec des étudiants,
qu'ils rendaient des devoirs semestriels
qui semblaient être bien supérieurs à leur niveau de vocabulaire.
Elle a commencé à poser des questions
et a découvert qu'il y avait une base de données
où les étudiants athlètes pouvaient trouver des devoirs et les rendre.
Elle a ensuite découvert que certains de ses collègues
plaçaient les étudiants dans des faux cours
afin qu'ils puissent continuer à jouer.
Quand Mary a découvert cela, elle en a été indignée.
Elle a décidé d'aller voir son superviseur direct.
Mais il n'a rien fait.
Mary a ensuite essayé d'aller voir un administrateur interne à l'université.
Il n'a rien fait.
Que se passe-t-il quand personne n'écoute ?
Vous faites un blog.
Mary a décidé de développer un blog.
Son blog a fait le buzz en 24 heures
et elle a été contactée par un journaliste.
Quand elle a été contactée par ce journaliste,
son identité a été connue.
Elle a été exposée.
Quand elle a été exposée, elle a été rétrogradée
et a reçu des menaces de morts pour du sport universitaire.
Mary n'a rien fait de mal. Elle n'a pas participé à la fraude.
Elle pensait vraiment donner une voix
aux étudiants qui ne pouvaient pas parler.
Mais sa loyauté a été remise en question.
Sa fiabilité et ses motivations.
Un lanceur d'alerte ne finit pas toujours
rétrogradé ou menacé de mort.
En 2002, ceci était la couverture du magazine « Time »
où nous honorions trois courageuses lanceuses d'alerte
pour leur décision de se manifester au nom de la vérité.
Quand vous considérez la recherche,
22% des lanceurs d'alerte rapportent des représailles.
Une grande partie de la population signalent et ne subit pas de représailles
et cela me donne espoir.
Voici Kathe.
Kathe Swanson est une secrétaire municipale de Dixon à la retraite.
Un jour, Kathe faisait son travail, comme toujours,
et elle est tombée sur un cas assez intéressant.
C'était la fin du mois
et Kathe réalisait son rapport sur la trésorerie pour la ville
et, en général, sa patronne, Rita Crundwell,
lui donnait une liste de comptes et disait :
« Kathe, appelle la banque et demande ces comptes précis. »
Et Kathe faisait son travail.
Mais ce jour-là,
Rita n'était pas présente et Kathe était occupée.
Elle a décroché le téléphone, appelé la banque et dit :
« Faxez-moi tous les comptes ».
Quand elle a reçu le fax, elle a vu qu'il y avait un compte
ayant des retraits et des dépôts
dont elle n'avait pas connaissance.
C'était un compte géré uniquement par Rita.
Kathe a regardé les informations, les a rapportées à son superviseur direct,
le maire de l'époque, M. Burke,
et cela a mené à une vaste enquête, qui a duré six mois.
On a découvert que la chef de Kathe, Rita Crundwell, détournait de l'argent.
Elle avait détourné 53 millions de dollars en l'espace de 20 ans
et Kathe est tombée sur cela.
Kathe est une héroïne.
J'ai eu la chance
d'interviewer Kathe pour mon documentaire, « Tous les chevaux de la reine ».
Kathe n'était pas en quête de célébrité.
Pendant très longtemps, elle n'a pas voulu me parler,
mais grâce à une traque stratégique, elle m'a accordé une interview.
(Rires)
Elle était en quête de justice, pas de célébrité.
Si Kathe n'avait pas été là,
cette fraude aurait-elle jamais été découverte ?
Souvenez-vous de cet article de « Forbes » dont je parlais,
sur lequel je travaillais.
je l'ai publié et quelque chose de fantastique est arrivé.
J'ai commencé à recevoir des mails de lanceurs d'alerte à travers le monde.
Alors que je recevais ces mails et que je leur répondais,
il y avait un thème commun dans tous les messages reçus
et ce thème était :
ils disaient tous cela : « J'ai lancé l'alerte, les gens me détestent.
J'ai été viré, mais devinez quoi ?
Si je le pouvais, je recommencerais. »
En continuant à lire ce message, tous ces messages,
j'ai pensé à ce que je pouvais partager avec mes étudiants.
J'ai réuni toutes les informations et voici ce que j'ai appris.
Il est important que nous cultivions l'espoir.
Les lanceurs d'alerte sont pleins d'espoir.
Malgré les idées reçues,
ce ne sont pas des employés mécontents qui ont une dent contre l'entreprise.
Leur espoir est ce qui les pousse à se manifester.
Nous devons aussi cultiver l'engagement.
Les lanceurs d'alerte sont engagés.
C'est cette passion envers leur organisation
qui fait qu'ils ont envie de se manifester.
Les lanceurs d'alerte sont humbles.
Ils ne sont pas en quête de célébrité mais ils sont en quête de justice.
Nous devons cultiver le courage.
Les lanceurs d'alerte sont courageux.
Souvent, ils ont sous-estimé
l'impact que lancer l'alerte aura sur leur famille
mais ils continuent de s'exprimer
sur combien il est difficile de dissimuler la vérité.
Cela étant dit, j'aimerais vous laisser avec un nom supplémentaire : Peter Buxtun.
Peter Buxtun était un employé de 27 ans du service public de santé américain.
Il a été engagé pour interviewer des gens
qui avaient des maladies sexuellement transmissibles.
Durant son travail,
il a remarqué une étude clinique réalisée au sein de l'organisation.
C'était une étude qui considérait la progression de la syphilis non soignée.
Il y avait 600 hommes afro-américains
dans cette étude.
On les avait incités à participer
en leur donnant des examens médicaux gratuits, une assurance funéraire.
Ce qu'il s'est passé durant cette étude
est que l'on a découvert que la pénicilline aide à soigner la syphilis.
Ce que Peter a remarqué
est que l'on n'a pas donné
de la pénicilline aux participants de l'étude
pour soigner leur syphilis.
Les participants ne le savaient pas.
De façon similaire à Mary, Peter a essayé de le signaler à ses superviseurs internes
mais personne n'a écouté.
Peter a pensé que cela était tout à fait injuste
et a réessayé de le signaler.
Finalement, il a parlé à un journaliste -- très similaire au cas de Mary.
En 1972, voici la une du « New York Times » :
« Étude américaine :
les victimes de la syphilis non soignées pendant 40 ans »
On connaît cela aujourd'hui
comme l'expérience de Tuskegee sur la syphilis.
Peter était le lanceur d'alerte.
Qu'est-il arrivé aux 600 hommes en question ?
Vingt-huit hommes sont morts de la syphilis.
Cent sont morts des complications de la syphilis,
quarante femmes ont été infectées
et 10 enfants sont nés avec la syphilis congénitale.
Quels seraient ces nombres
sans l'acte courageux, téméraire de Peter ?
Nous sommes tous liés à Peter.
Si vous connaissez quelqu'un dans un essai clinique,
la raison pour laquelle nous avons le consentement éclairé
vient de l'acte courageux de Peter.
Je vais vous poser une question.
La question initiale, une variation de la question initiale.
Combien d'entre nous ont déjà utilisé le terme
« mouchard », « rat »,
« rapporteur »,
« serpent »,
« fouine »,
« balance » ?
Quelqu'un ?
Avant d'éprouver le besoin de le faire à nouveau,
j'aimerais que vous réfléchissiez.
Ce pourrait être la Mary, le Peter, la Kathe de ce monde.
Vous pourriez être la personne façonnant l'histoire
ou cela pourrait être la personne façonnant la vôtre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)